hello what's going on guys
this is rob and as an update i'm
actually going to be moving pretty soon
so i will be incognito for the next few
weeks or so
but i want to make sure you guys didn't
think that i was bailing on you guys
abandoning the channel or anything like
that
it's just you know moving is moving so
what can you say
um in any event um i know that marvel
agents of shield had released the
episode tahiti and at the end of
the episode tahiti a lot of you guys had
questions about what that alien was that
coulson was looking at
i will say that it was most likely a
cree and we'll do a video about the cree
later on
but for right now i gotta get stuff
moved so
i will catch you guys later peace